لنتحدث الان على المال فمن المقرر ان
تزداد احجام المدفوعات غير النقديه عالميا
باكثر من 80% في الفتره بين عامين 20 20
وحتى عام 20 و 25 بحسب تحليل اجرته شبكه
الاستشارات العالميه برايس وتر هاوس كوبر
وفي الواقع تعمل العديد من الاقتصادات على
تحرير نفسها تماما من المعاملات القائمه
على النقد والاتجاه هو بالتاكيد للمعاملات
غير النقديه على اشكالها المختلفه من
خدمات عبر الانترنت او عبر الهاتف او حتى
المدفوعات الا تلاموسيه وغيرها هذا
الاتجاهات ساره مع انتشار كورونا لتقليل
مخاطر العدوى التي تحملها العملات الورقيه
واعتبارا من 20 21 اصبح
76% من البالغين حول العالم يمتلكون حسابا
في احد البنوك او المؤسسات الماليه الاخرى
المزيد من الارقام مع كلامه
من المتوقع ان تصل القيمه الاجماليه في
قطاع المدفوعات الرقميه حول العالم الى
8.99 مليون دولار امريكي خلال 2022 واليكم
المزيد من الارقام خمسه ريونات و490 مليار
دولار من المعاملات غير النقديه من
المتوقع ان تذهب للتجاره الرقميه التي
تمثل اكبر شريحه في هذا القطاع
19% فقط هو اجمالي المدفوعات النقديه في
الولايات المتحده خلال عام 20 20 80% من
المعاملات النقديه في الولايات المتحده
للمدفعات الاقل 25 دولار امريكي المثير
الانتباه 62% من الامريكيين يعترفون بانهم
اقل عرضه للانفاق الزائد عند الدفع نقدر
اما في منطقه اليورو 49% من نسبه مدفوعات
غير النقديه كانت مناصيب البطاقات البنكيه
خلال العام 2001 2020 واخيرا واحد فاصل
تسعه فقد دفع بنكيه هو متوسط نصيب المواطن
في منطقه اليورو خلال العام الماضي وهو
ارتفاع بالنسبه اربعه الفصل سته بالمئه عن
عام 2020
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تورنا دائما
اهلا بك هل فعلا اليوم يمكن القول
المدفوعات الالكترونيه ستقضي على الكاش
عليها من زمان
الاصغر هذا الشيء يمكن قضت عليه من زمان
بس ما زال كاش كينج
10 معاملات سته منها ما زالت تقام بالكاش
خصوصا في البلدان
الاوروبيه مثلا او في امريكا
اكبر بالعمر
بالاموال في البيت او يحملون كشفيه يعني
بحسب احد اعضاء
المركزي الالماني قال انه ما زال الشخص
يحتفظ تقريبا
تنزلي بالنسبه في المانيا و300 يورو من في
حقيبته فما زال الكاش هناك لانه الاشخاص
اكبر يفضلون التعامل
بالكاش ولكن في المنطقه هنا يمكن هذا
الشيء هيتغير قريبا طبعا كورونا كان لها
احد الاسباب اللي ادت الى الانتقال اكثر
الى الديجيتال او المدفوعات الرقميه مثل
ما قلت في همم
ما هو حجم صناعه طباعه النقد وما هو وما
هي وتيره النمو
كان هناك اعتماد اكثر على المدفوعات
الرقميه بس ما قامت البنوك المركزيه
باعطاء حزم تحفيزيه للاشخاص يعني في
اوروبا مثلا قاموا همم في اوروبا وفي
امريكا قاموا باعطاء رواتب للاشخاص فقط
قاموا بطاعه المال بس امريكا تبعت العام
الماضي 13 مليار دولار عفوا 13 مليون
دولار بس في امريكا العام الماضي يتم
طباعتها فما هذا القطاع ما زال كبير ينمو
بواتيره 4% عالميا ومن المتوقع ان يصل الى
اكثر من 15 مليار دولار في عام 20 25 فما
زال ينمو بواتير لا باس بها وما زال مثل
ما قلنا الكاشه
افضل من الورق ما مدى دقه او صحه هذه
المعلومه وهذه المقوله اقتصاديه مبدئيا
قبل كم يوم وهو كان همم هناك شركات من
جميع الجهات طبعا الشركات التي تصنع
البلاستيك تقول لبلاستيك افضل همم شركات
التي تصنع الورق او القطن هو يعني تقول
انه القطن افضل فحسب كل شركه بس من ناحيه
البيئه انه يقال انه البلاستيك عمره اطول
بكثير من عمر همم يعني على الاقل اربعه
اضعاف عمر العمله الورقيه العمله الورقيه
كل ما تتلف يتم استبدالها تقريبا كل همم
خمس سنوات الى سنوات بينما البلاستيك يتم
استبداله تقريبا كل 10 الى 15 سنه ويقال
انه بحسب الارقام والخبراء انه تم توفير
نحو همم على الاقل مليار دولار على مدى 10
سنوات لل اا للدول التي اختارت ان تطبع
البلاستيك بدلا عن الكاش شكرا جزيلا لك يا
سمر